[inaudible]
thank you so much.
I appreciate the introduction and a real happy to be here with you all today.
Um,
so it's a privilege to come out and speak at Google and share my story and I
look forward to giving you an overview of what motivates me to start this
company and how I try to make a difference and all that I do here through this
company,
Purple Carrot and uh,
look forward to our discussion.
So I thought I'd start off today with an image of our four kids.
Uh,
it's not necessarily to ask you to Ooh,
not how cute they are though.
I do think they're pretty cute.
I'm a little biased as their father.
Uh,
but you know,
these guys really give me a ton of motivation and inspiration to succeed and
make a difference in the world.
And I think about the world that they're going to inherit and quite frankly,
the world that each of us is going to be inheriting in the years ahead.
And it's pretty scary to think about what's happening right now.
Uh,
I see myself as an optimist.
I'm usually a half full kind of guy.
But when you look out and you read the news stories and you see some of the
data,
uh,
it's enough to give you pause about what our future looks like.
And there's some people that might say it's even too late to make some
meaningful changes that could alter the trajectory of the way our planet is
headed.
But I'd like to believe that if we start acting together in a meaningful and
deliberate way,
there's a good chance that we can change the course of our future.
Uh,
I want to think about creating a great world for these kids to grow up in.
And so,
uh,
this is my story.
So I'm borrowing an image that,
uh,
was,
I was reminded by from Leonardo Dicaprio and he was serving as the host of a new
film that came out a few months ago called before the flood.
I'm not sure if any of you have seen that,
but,
uh,
this picture really resonated with me.
I was an art history major in college many years ago.
And,
uh,
this is a,
image called the garden of earthly delights by Hieronymus Bosch.
It was made about 600 years ago and it's never been more timely to take a look
at this.
So,
uh,
it's a very large tryptic.
If we take a look at the first,
uh,
leftmost part of the painting,
you see,
it's a really nice idyllic setting.
There's plenty of light.
There's not many people.
It's not overcrowded.
Uh,
people seem pretty happy.
It's relaxed,
it's open.
It feels pretty nice.
As we shift into the middle panel of the triptych,
you started to see things changing a bit.
There's a lot of overcrowding.
It's a ton of people.
There is some partying,
there's sex,
there's drinking,
people were having a great time.
And,
uh,
it's starts to take a shift from the earlier stages that we saw in that image,
into something that starts to get a little bit like overcrowding and the
situation that we might be living in today.
And then at the end is we had to,
the far right part of the image,
you see,
it's really decided to leave very dark.
There's death,
there's destruction,
there's fires.
Uh,
there's a lot of concerning elements to this image.
I think I can see an image of Donald Trump and the bottom right corner there.
And it's just a scary view of what might be happening in our future.
And a,
for a guy that painted this more than 600 years ago,
it's worth taking note to think about what this could mean for all of us in our
future.
So as I,
uh,
I've heard in the opening,
I spent a lot of my life in the pharmaceutical industry about 20 years promoting
the value of western medicine and still strongly believe in the value that,
uh,
the drugs that are created in this country are great and can be life changing
and life saving.
But with all those medicines that are available to us today and all the
awareness that is happening in our country,
there's still some pretty scary statistics that are worth pointing out.
For starters,
70% of us are overweight or obese.
And that's just a shocking stat to see.
Um,
the way people are consuming food and the way they exercise or don't exercise to
be in that type of situation.
One in three of us are going to die of heart disease and that actually makes
heart disease,
America's number one killer and largely driven by the food choice that we make.
And on top of that,
50% of us are going to be diabetic or prediabetic by 2030 and these are three
health conditions that are all chronic in nature and that all can be reduced or
reversed by incorporating a plant based diet.
But I think if we continue to eat the sugary,
you know,
me donuts and fried chicken and other things that are bringing a lot of uh,
health issues upon us,
things are not going to change
environmentally.
It's not much better when you look out and you think about 50% of our land is
currently allocated to animal agriculture.
And to me that just feels like an incredibly inefficient use of our land.
And it's,
you know,
our choice to continue to raise cattle that is only raised for slaughter,
largely raised for slaughter to feed our massive consumption of meat and dairy
and these sort of oversized supersized type of appetites that people have
developed.
Now if you're a farmer and you were fortunate enough to have an acre of land to
work with and you decided,
well,
what should I do with that acre of land?
And you said the heck I'm going to raise cattle,
we can think about how a farmer's going to think about that product and how they
could use that,
uh,
animal to make a profit and sell food into the marketplace.
And the way they could use that product.
And if you're efficient with that cattle usage in that way where you're raised
that cattle,
you probably get about 375 pounds of beef that you're able to sell in the
marketplace.
If you think that same acre of land,
you can get 37,500 pounds of plant based food from the same space.
So if you stop and think about the amount of hunger that is pervasive across
this world and the growth of our population to be north of 9 billion people in
2050,
we got to think about how we could change the way we consume food,
how we produce food and the food choices that we make.
They could be a redeploying some of our land and our precious resources to feed
those who are so hungry.
And so we need
from a water consumption perspective,
the meat and dairy industry is associated with the use of about one third of all
the fresh water on our planet.
If you just stop and think about how much water is required to raise cattle to
uh,
continue to sort of move that process through the system,
it's taking up a tremendous amount of very limited resource and coming out here
to California,
I think about that even more as the city.
This state rather has experienced a tremendous drought over the last five years.
Things seem to be getting a little bit better,
but not a whole lot.
And it's a concerning statement to think about how water is being allocated when
it could be used in a far different way.
Okay.
Building on that,
the headline from January this year,
was it the earth headache temperature record for the third year in a row?
And that talks about how we're going this incredible change in our environment
that is considered to be unsustainable by most scientists.
Though some would tell you that it's a fake news.
I would beg to disagree.
Uh,
Arctic Sea ice hit a record low in the North Pole just a couple of months ago
and that certainly clearly driven off of the global warming issues.
And just last week there was a massive iceberg that broke off of the coast of
Antarctica and it's just,
you know,
more bad news after more bad news.
So again,
I'm not trying to paint such a miserable picture of the,
of the world and what's happening,
but it really points to some issues that we have.
Uh,
and a lot of those problems with respect to the environment come off of this
incredible,
uh,
use of greenhouse gases are the emission of greenhouse gases.
And about 18% of that is associated with agricultural farming.
And so that type of practice is only causing a greater problems in our
environment.
And uh,
that trumps all of the um,
transportation emissions that people seem to associate with global warming.
But in the agriculture is the number one culprit of that.
So when you think about all that data that I just shared with you,
it's probably not hard to look back at this.
Uh,
this image again of the garden of earthly delights and think about this image
there on the far right is not too far off from where we could be headed if we
don't make some changes.
And it was really for that reason that I decided to start my own company three
years ago called the purple carrot.
The purple carrot is the only a hundred percent plant based meal kit on the
market and we provide all of the raw premeasured ingredients that people need to
cook three meals every week that are exclusively plant based.
Our whole mission is that we want to get people to eat more plants largely for
the reasons that I described.
And we think that there's a bright future in that and that we need to help more
and more people start to think about eating more plants as a common way of life.
It's a little bit of a weird statement to think about eating plants.
I've never loved the term plant based because I feel like most of us don't go
out there and think about,
you know,
God,
I can't wait to have some plants today.
It's not really a crave worthy,
uh,
way of thinking about it.
But,
uh,
there's a lot to that that we can try to uncover.
Uh,
it's awesome that here at Google,
Eric Schmidt made some predictions and comments about some of the most important
tech trends that are out there.
And the first one that he commented on was nerds over cattle,
which is idea of using technology to drive the greater use of plant based foods
and meat alternatives.
And it's great that he was so far ahead of the curve to be recommending that as
a material,
a way we can improve the environment.
And just saw yesterday this article in Fast Company about your quest to develop
a plant based power dish more popular than meat.
So I'm not sure if you were even aware of this as employees that uh,
there's been some adjustments in the amount of meat content in the burgers and
it's moving into some more uh,
mushrooms,
uh,
without,
calling that out to see if people still enjoy it as much.
So,
uh,
no matter the way you're approaching getting to a plant based and worlds,
certainly here at Google,
it's nice to see that being so well embraced.
So it's a big misconception that purple carrot is just for vegans.
Uh,
when I started the company almost three years ago,
I always said this was Vegan food for non vegans.
And I'm really thrilled to see that as our data represents,
82% of our customer base are omnivorous and we have welcome surveys.
When people sign up to subscribe to our service and they tell us what their
meal,
uh,
their dietary choices and preferences are.
And so the fact that four out of five of them continue to eat sort of a full
omnivorous diet is very encouraging because I think that's where the market is.
That's where the opportunity is to change people's habits,
uh,
exist and we're excited to be doing our part to help move them along.
Uh,
we even created a word to characterize who our customers are.
someone who is what we call it,
balance a terrarium.
And this is a word we coined back in November of last year.
The idea is that it's someone who still can embrace a plant based diet but
doesn't totally divorced themselves from eating meat,
some dairy and some eggs.
I think it's fair to recognize that it's really hard to be a Vegan.
I'm not Vegan.
I eat a lot of plant based foods,
but um,
you know,
the draw for dairy and some animal protein is pretty pronounced and sort of deep
seated in our evolution as human beings.
And for those who are Vegan and who stick with a Vegan Diet,
I think it's largely driven from ethical beliefs.
And I really admire people who have the ability to uh,
let that limit their food choices.
But for the majority of people out there,
it's really hard to stick with the Diet of any type really.
Um,
and Vegan is extremely limited in choices.
There's certainly a lot more today than there ever has been.
But our goal is to try to move people along a continuum that almost looks at us
as sort of a gateway drug of sorts that the more you start craving and enjoying
plant based meals,
the less and less fuel are going to start to want to eat animal protein.
The last you want to have dairy and the more mindful you'll be about the food
choices that you,
uh,
you continue to make.
So you can proudly say you are a balanced a terrarium.
So the trends are certainly with us.
This is about a pretty cool chart worth sharing.
It was a,
um,
an image I captured from Google trends and uh,
all the bright people at this company have this,
a novel tool that allows guys like me to log in and type in the word plant based
and see the trends over the last five years.
And it's pretty amazing to look over here and see this type of,
of spike in the last few months around plant based.
So it gives us a lot of hope and confidence that we're making a difference and
getting on people's radar screen as the general consciousness is and increasing
about the importance and value of plant based eating.
Thought it might be worth just taking a moment or two talking a bit more about
the category.
Um,
I'm not sure by show of hands how many people have,
have or use a meal kit.
So you get the idea.
Um,
it was started by a Matt who launched Blue Apron back in 2012.
And uh,
nick from plated,
uh,
was at Harvard with him as well.
And the two of those guys started similar companies.
Blue Apron plated right around the same time.
And Blue Apron was really runaway with sort of the dominant brand in the meal
kit category.
Hellofresh came over from Europe,
which is where the whole concept started.
And those three companies sort of began the process about five years ago.
And it's amazing to think that this industry is only five years old.
The idea is that consumers can subscribe to these services and they are shipped
all of the raw premeasured ingredients and little baggies or,
uh,
bottles and containers that,
really should make it a lot easier for people to cook at home every week.
Uh,
you know,
my wife and I would always talk and in the morning and be sitting there having
breakfast and she might turn to me and say,
honey,
what do we having for dinner tonight?
And even though I started this company three years ago,
I still get that question a lot,
but,
uh,
it's made a little bit simpler thinking about,
you know,
maybe the choices are,
well,
which purple carrot meals do we have in our refrigerator this week?
So,
uh,
the idea is that it's really intended to make it easier for people to cook.
They all come with these colorful recipe cards that explain step by step
instructions with the before and after shots of what you're looking to create.
Uh,
provides sort of a curated experience of meals that all tend to go together in
that particular week.
Uh,
they can align specific to dare Terry needs or dietary preferences that you
might have.
And it's a lot of fun.
It's a nice way to learn how to cook.
And I think there's a lot of millennials who are also,
I'm not as informed about how to cook as some of the older generations and look
for guidance and meal kits,
do a great job of providing that training and sort sorta tutorial experience.
So from a business perspective though,
it's really become a very dynamic category.
Uh,
what you see here on the screen or a couple of images about the different meal
kit delivery companies in the food tech space and the growth from largely driven
off of this part of the country or in Silicon Valley,
the massive influx of cash and capital into the food tech space.
Food was sort of considered the new tech from a few years ago and a lot of money
has rushed in.
A lot of it has been focused around the immediate delivery.
And I think that those of you here can attest to the commonality of on demand,
everything being here in 10 or 15 minutes.
And just that incredible mindset that is really dominant here in this part of
the country that may be less pronounced in other places that are certainly far
less concentrated with population.
And a lot of hope has been placed on these rapid delivery options that
companies,
but a lot of them are starting to fail or have been failing.
Uh,
if they're not closed down already on these,
um,
sort of VC dreams of where and how fast they're can be disruption in the
marketplace.
The category around food tech has just exploded though and you can see from this
image the incredible amount of logos and brands and players that are all trying
to pursue and make a bit of a difference and find their spot with their own
offering.
Somewhere around the way people consume food.
Uh,
as a frame of reference,
the grocery business is about $800 billion category.
The meal kit category is far smaller at about $5 billion with a lot of room for
growth certainly.
But the way people consume food and how frequently they do it is a big reason
for a lot of these companies coming into play to try to disrupt the space.
Uh,
from a meal kit perspective,
I'm really honored to see our name and sort of a pretty short list of companies
that are considered leaders in the category.
Um,
what I show you here,
what I would consider the leaders,
I probably would add sun basket maybe at this point,
maybe instead of peach dish.
Um,
but there's a relatively small group.
We now have companies who I think have found their niche,
who are doing well,
who are growing.
Uh,
and where I guess I would look at this is that purple carrot stands out as the
only one that offers a 100% plant based meals.
The rest of them really are focusing on pretty much the same type of offering.
It's not to disparage those offerings,
they're all great,
but I think that it leads to so much more competition for the same type of
consumer who is looking to acquire who the companies are looking to acquire as
subscribers and offering a pretty identical offering from any of these.
And given the substantial venture capital investment that these,
that these companies have received,
they're able to use those dollars to offer free trials and you know,
first box free or 50% off these orders.
And it creates a pretty promiscuous user base where you can game system,
you can try any one of these companies including ours,
uh,
and shift,
you know,
each different week and get discounts.
Ours,
we don't discount ours much kind of for that reason.
Uh,
we don't want to play that game,
but there's a big,
big shift of the way people are thinking about how they consume meals and the
category is growing.
I think it's a pretty exciting space to be in and it's an honor to be in this
short list.
Now,
there is a new player in the category that just came out a couple of weeks ago.
You might've heard of this company,
they're called Amazon.
Uh,
it's a little bit scary when,
you know,
being in this space,
you see a name like that announcing that they're entering the category.
Uh,
you know,
Jeff Bezos and team are pretty dominant force and what they want to do and
disrupt.
You've got to give them a lot of respects and belief that they can do whatever
they really want to do given their infrastructure,
their knowledge,
their financial capabilities,
supply chain control,
uh,
reach,
consumer engagement.
The list goes on.
So,
you know,
seeing that it was both like,
oh no,
great,
and then great.
Oh No,
you know,
that sort of happening that in the same moment when I saw that news.
But,
uh,
they're now into the mix with a meal gets thrown own.
So we'll see.
I think is still pretty much in a Beta phase,
offering it to a limited number of people in the Seattle area through hello
fresh but,
uh,
in through a Amazon fresh rather.
But,
um,
it probably won't be long before they become slightly more involved in this
category.
They even filed a trademark to do meal kits and that has been a bit of a pain
point for blue apron,
which went public just the end of June,
right around the same time this is happening.
So it's pretty current information that I'm sharing here and it does make me
wonder if at Salzburg did something to piss off Jeff Bezos because it's,
it's shocking to see the timing and I feel a little bad for him.
But you know,
when,
uh,
they launched their IPO at $10 a share,
just the end of June,
it's now trading around six 75 or so.
And it's really been under pressure largely from a Amazon's decision to move
into the meal kit space.
Uh,
they've really been,
um,
sort of battered down by the news that Amazon is doing that they're also of
course,
uh,
further hurt by the fact that Amazon is also announced that they are buying
whole foods market for almost $14 billion.
Uh,
and the timing of those two announcements came right after the other one before
the other actually.
And that's been a big problem for blue apron.
As Amazon sits out there as a big competitor in the space.
It certainly isn't competitive.
Uh,
to me it purple carrot in our business.
Um,
so interesting times,
uh,
I thought it was worth sharing this image that I found that was incredible to
see it as much as you see how they negatively impacted Blue Apron and their
recent IPO in their stock price.
How as soon as Amazon announced the acquisition of whole foods,
what it did to the grocery category to see Walmart,
Kroger,
target,
and Costco get totally pummeled.
Uh,
the only one that went up of course was whole foods through that acquisition.
Um,
I believe that also Amazon announced they're moving into replacing a geek squad
at best buy,
best buy offers traditionally and best buy had the similar type of negative
impacts.
So Amazon's a really substantial player in the category.
Um,
and probably other than Google is a sort of dominant player out there.
Uh,
you have to give them a lot of respect for what they can do.
So it sort of feels like this is the moment where I'm that little gun in the
diaper practically and you know,
facing up against this,
a really strong competitor to think how in God's name am I going to be able to
compete with these huge players?
And it is.
Um,
it's really been a challenge,
I think since I launched the company where I wasn't a food guy,
I was not a VC.
I'd come from a 20 year history in the pharmaceutical world and I think people
thought you're launching a Vegan product is a very small percentage of vegans
out there.
I think depending on what study you believe,
it's anywhere from two to 6% of the population.
And people said,
Andy,
why doesn't people,
why does it Blue Apron?
Just go do their own Vegan line?
And it was really hard to get out there.
So I'm proud of the fact that here we are almost three years later,
uh,
a part of the national conversation around meal kits,
but it's only gonna get harder and more competitive.
And so I'll spend last couple of minutes talking about what I see is a part of
our ways to succeed.
Because the guy in the screen here,
you may know him,
his name is Guy Kawasaki,
a guy who is an incredible thinker.
Uh,
he's,
uh,
now a venture capitalist.
He was most well known,
I think for being the first evangelists at apple computers.
And now probably 30 plus years ago,
guy was out there evangelizing apple to,
uh,
to schools to get apple computer to be known.
And it was a,
you know,
a very little known company back then.
And Guy was,
uh,
this very innovative thinker and he has,
evolved into the world of VC and he wrote a book called art of the start.
And I read that book back in end of 2006 actually.
And it's always stayed with me.
And,
um,
some great things.
So if anyone's in here thinking about starting their own company,
I'd highly recommend you take a look at this book,
Art of the start.
And the first thing that guy talks about in there is this idea that he says make
meaning.
It's different from make money.
Uh,
and while he is a venture capitalist and thinks about that and it's probably
made a ton of money in his life.
Uh,
and as much as I want to make money in mind,
the idea about sort of focusing your decisions and deciding how you want to go
about building a company is having it grounded with the underpinning about make
meaning.
And that's been really pronounced in the way I've thought about building out
purple carrot about providing something that's plant based that has all the
benefits that we talked about upfront.
Uh,
that creates a meaningful opportunity to establish ourselves and do something
that is inherently different from a lot of the other competitors in the
category.
So I really love this artist's name is Hugh macleod and he creates something
called gaping void.
So,
uh,
if you're not familiar with fewer his work,
I'd encourage you to check out gaping void.com and you can sign up and get this
daily feed a of his doodles.
And this one I saw several years ago and it also stayed with me a lot,
which is this idea of living on the edges are not at all.
And you know,
seeing that it just,
it felt like the whole idea was to stand out and be different and be
distinguished and it's,
you know,
scary and it's exciting.
Um,
but that's how you'll get noticed.
And I,
sorry,
I followed up on that image recently to see a bit more about what he wrote
about.
I thought I'd read this to you.
He says,
just as sheep moved to the center of the flock for purely survival reasons,
so to human beings,
it's why we wear Khakis and join tennis clubs.
But some of us moved to the edges for the exact same reason.
Survival.
If we stay in the middle,
we're just going to get creamed like everybody else wants the market moves on.
I think Google is probably by the most innovative,
Edgy company out there.
So I would imagine this resonates.
Uh,
but I thought that was pretty cool to see that.
And again,
going to that edge of providing sort of Vegan food for non vegans was the edge.
Uh,
people said,
why don't you just offer a vegetarian option,
which to me would be far more mainstream and simplistic,
but all the other big guys have vegetarian options and none of them offer Vegan.
And so that was the approach to go to the edge.
So another guy who I love is a guy by the name of Seth Godin and he's
photographed here for you.
And Seth is been one of the most pronounced influences,
uh,
in my whole life.
And,
uh,
I think he's a genius of a guy.
He's written a ton of books.
If you don't know Seth,
uh,
really encourage you to check out Seth goden.com and sign up for his blog can
click on his bald head and a,
you can get his blog every day in every day for years.
He writes an incredible blog that you'll get in your inbox for free.
And he's just a brilliant writer.
He's written a lot of books and he does wonderful work.
So I can't say enough great things about him,
but one of the books that he's written of the 18 or 20 bucks or so out there is
a book called Purple Cow.
And purple cow is all about being remarkable and gets a transform your business
by being remarkable is the subtext.
And the storyline with purple cow is that,
you know,
if you're driving out,
he was driving with his family and France,
I believe,
and he was going along and pass this pastor and there's cows and they stop in it
first,
I think,
no,
that's cool.
There's these cows.
And then in a minute it's not that interesting when there's just all these cows.
And he said,
imagine if you saw a purple cow,
you would stop the car,
you'd get out,
you'd take pictures,
you tell all your friends.
And it was this idea of creating a purple cow or something that is remarkable,
that forces you almost given its remarkable nature to tell people about it and
speak to others and spread the word.
So when I think about purple cow,
that was sort of the genesis of the name of my company,
Purple Carrot.
I remember thinking about starting this company and walking down Park Avenue
South in New York City one night.
And it just hit me and I said,
okay,
that's the name of my Vegan company.
Purple Cow,
Purple Carrot Rather,
still slip.
And uh,
so it's,
uh,
it's been great and it's really about,
you know,
being different.
So,
um,
thought about,
well,
how could we be remarkable in our space?
What can we do to stand out?
Uh,
what you see on the screen here is an image of,
um,
of me talking about one of our meals.
And,
uh,
this dish here is a [inaudible],
which most people would probably don't even know how to pronounce and took me a
little while to get that right for the video.
Um,
but the idea is that,
you know,
it came from a a moment that my wife and I had a few months earlier where the
last meal we had at home that week was called Tofu Halloumi and it was one of
our meals for purple carrot.
And I didn't know what Halloumi was and I wasn't that excited about what that
seemed like it was going to be.
And we ended up making it and it was one of my favorite purple carrot meals I've
had in three years.
And I thought,
God,
you know,
people really need to understand what our meals are because we do have some
unique and not common names to our products or to our recipes each week.
And it,
it's part of the adventure of trying plant based meals.
Okonomiyaki is no different as far as not a commonplace name.
And so I felt like if I can get out there and talk about one of the three meals
every week through video,
post that to social as well as a share that over email to our database.
There might be another reason for someone who has all those choices from the
number of companies that I shared with you.
That instead of looking at something and saying,
hmm,
I've never heard of that,
I'm not going to take the risk of spending money on a product that's gonna make
me look foolish at home.
But hearing from me or someone on my company,
I was the one that they nominated to do it.
So I said,
okay.
Um,
unfortunately these of these,
um,
converted at about six times the rate of our typical emails.
So it's been really cool to see video and the conductivity we're building with
our customer base to create a real emotional connection with them so that they
feel connected to our product and that they feel a reason to stick with us and
to continue to subscribe,
uh,
and not maybe choose other options that they have on the marketplace.
Something else that feels very,
uh,
probably Google ask that maybe has already been developed here.
Um,
it's something that we are looking about releasing in a purple carrot app that
will soon to be developed that will allow people to track their impact and to
create sort of a gamification system of sorts that as you use purple carrot and
you can track and see how much water you've saved,
how much carbon emissions you've reduced through your choice of meals,
uh,
and create sort of a competitive gamified experience from you and your friends.
You know,
this idea of a network effect that your product is how can you make your product
better when your friends are using it also,
right?
So the famous example is the first guy who bought a fax machine and what he was
thinking to think who is going to send a fax to if nobody else had the machine.
But you know,
how can you make purple carrot better,
more interesting,
more sticky to our customer base so that,
you know,
if you can create this gamified approach to make you feel like you're a part of
something larger than yourself,
by tracking your impact and seeing how this month,
by eating these meals as compared to more traditional meals,
that would be similar.
You've saved thousands and thousands of gallons of water.
It's like,
you know,
leaving your shower on for three months instead,
you've eaten these meals and so,
uh,
ways to do that.
So we're excited about what that will look like for us.
We've also partnered with guys,
some of you may have seen,
his name is Tom Brady.
Uh,
we've partnered with Tom and his colleagues at TB 12 back in March of this year.
So we're about a four or five months into that partnership.
Uh,
it's a three year engagement that we have with,
with him.
And you know,
Tom is at about an 80% plant based eater,
uh,
and he represents to me the absolute pinnacle of success for a human being to
achieve all that he's achieved.
Uh,
he turns 40 next week and he's playing at the top of his game and he assigns a
lot of value to the foods that he eats as a key component to his longterm
success.
Uh,
so TB 12 is all about sleep and muscle pliability and nutrition and mental
energy and hydration.
And so as five of those key components exist for them,
purple carrot fit in really nicely.
And when we went out and spoke with those guys,
uh,
last fall we talked to them about purple carrot and the potential to create a
long term partnership and develop the TB 12 performance meals.
And so we're really thrilled that,
uh,
Tom is a partner with us and has allowed us to create sort of a new,
not a new line extension from purple carrots.
So we have our core meals that feed two people,
we have a family plan and then now we offer these TB 12 performance meals,
which are gluten free as well as plant based and slightly higher in protein.
And so it's a nother way to differentiate and distinguish ourselves.
And through our partnership,
uh,
we've created,
tried to take that a level deeper by offering exclusive content that takes us
beyond a meal kit.
But now you're really a part of the TB 12 line.
A lot of people have signed up because they love Tom Brady,
uh,
um,
one of them.
But there's also a whole desire for health.
And so what we've created through these TB 12 newsletters is exclusive content
that you can only get by being a subscriber.
And so,
uh,
every other month we put out these,
these newsletters are eight pages.
They are all designed in house.
This is an example of one of the spreads that shows,
you know,
various summer produce,
different sauces that uh,
Tom might enjoy and things that are consistent with that.
Uh,
we've featured 24 hours with Tom.
We've got questions with Tom,
we've got sort of behind the scenes content that you're just not going to get
anywhere else.
And again,
that's sort of an exclusive piece of,
uh,
the way we can merchandise and make the most of this partnership.
We also have,
uh,
the nice opportunity to send our subscribers a letter from Tom.
You see that in the far left side with the little bit of a creepy guy who's
there holding the image of Tom.
And then on the right,
it's actually a real,
um,
autographed binder.
Uh,
the Tom signed 12 of these.
Everything he does is in the 12 number.
Um,
as you can imagine with the number 12.
And so what we did is when you order our,
uh,
our product,
after your 12th boxes arrived,
after three months,
you'll get it,
wouldn't bind her.
That's got this TB 12 etching in it with the performance meals and it's a three
ring binder that,
uh,
where you can con uh,
retain an organized the recipe cards that we shipped that are also three hole
punched.
And so 12 lucky people received an autographed,
uh,
Tom Brady binder and people post on social and it just allows us to do things
that really no other meal kit can do.
Uh,
so we feel pretty good about where we're headed there.
And um,
you know,
sort of comes down to this image.
When I think about the sea of choices and what's out there,
how can we stand out and how can you take all these choices and say,
I'm the guy that they're going to pick.
Um,
and so,
uh,
that's what drives me to try to do that.
I'll leave you with this last image from a hue that I love and it just really
spoke to me and a lot of the words that he shared when he posted this image
about,
you know,
you try so hard and you're scared,
you wake up in the middle of the night,
you've got a pain in your side and you just do it cause you love it and you
believe in the future.
And so this idea of I love this and it's terrifying and I can tell you it is
terrifying.
It's a thrill.
It's an honor to do what I do.
Uh,
and I'm just looking to make a difference and,
uh,
hopefully we're succeeding.
So,
uh,
thank you so much for listening and we can get in touch with me with that
information there.
And I'm happy to take any questions from anyone here or remotely.
So thank you so much.
I was curious about like big food lobbying and like,
I'm sure,
I mean obviously lobbyists have a big influence on like policies that encourage
meat consumption and how much meat we sell in our grocery stores and
advertisements for cool steaks on the grill and all of that stuff.
So like,
do you like,
is there a way to like combat that because like,
I would like to see more companies like this advertised and like senators
fighting for plant based meals in public schools,
stuff like that.
Like,
yeah.
Are there any like,
things we could do to like scale this quickly or
thank you.
Uh,
I love the support.
and we just watched a documentary about two weeks ago called what the health,
uh,
I'm not sure if you've seen it yet,
but it's really worth checking out.
Um,
it,
it really highlights the inherent conflict that between big food and our
government and the presentation of,
of meals in the recommendations that are made,
uh,
and,
and also with,
um,
health advocacy groups with within the pharmaceutical world.
It was really concerning to see the,
um,
this misalignment of incentives where,
you know,
the American Diabetes Association or the American Heart Association,
which one would think as a consumer you can rely upon for good guidance.
And then you start to see the amount of money and the funding that comes in from
big industry.
So whether that's the pharmaceutical companies or the large food manufacturers,
you know,
candy companies,
meet companies,
dairy companies,
the works,
there's,
they're all part of that.
And you know,
their goal is to further perpetuate the consumption of the foods and the
products that they create and provide.
And there's that inherent misalignment.
So,
you know,
I,
it's a big task to,
um,
sort of fight big government.
I think documentaries like what the health to a really nice job of shining that
bright light.
Um,
and I think it's,
you know,
there's a bumper sticker that says,
when the,
when the people lead,
the leaders will follow something like that.
You know,
that it's that idea of that I think we have to start acting together,
talks about,
you know,
what I said at the beginning of this,
our world is,
you know,
on pretty precarious grounds.
Um,
and I think as more people start to make those changes,
it doesn't seem weird anymore to think about eating plant based and you know,
amaze out here in California how much choice there is and how conscious,
how aware of that is in,
and it's not everywhere like that.
Right.
And so I think the more it becomes more mainstream,
the more you see the growth of plant based searches,
uh,
the more leaders get involved.
And I think the more change that,
you know,
comes through a younger generation of millennials who are the,
a very large cohort who also were the ones that are most interested in
transparency in meat and dairy replacements,
that that's gonna start shifting policies that will enable more of us to succeed
through this.
So thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Um,
so my question is about how you source your recipes.
I've been like preparing plant based meals probably for about a year and a half.
Um,
and I've done several purple carrot recipes and I find that,
um,
there are very unique compared to a lot of the things you find on the Internet
in terms of like the ways that you can create like really interesting thing.
So for example,
there was a recipe where you made scallops out of mushrooms and which was really
awesome and tasted great.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm just wondering like where these ideas come from and like she was working on
the,
the recipes themselves.
Sure.
Yeah.
So by and large,
all the recipes that we make it purple carrot come from our own chefs.
We have on staff.
So back in,
we're,
we're based in the Boston area.
We've got about 30 employees,
uh,
on staff full time.
Uh,
two of those are chefs and we got a couple of other sort of sous chefs and
assistance to help order products for them to be testing in our test kitchen
back in Boston.
We do outsource our fulfillment.
And we have that happening in three centers in New York,
La,
in Ohio.
Um,
so our,
our corporate offices,
if you will,
they're not that corporate,
but,
uh,
the corporate office has these three folks and,
we have a test kitchen.
And so our,
our chefs are,
are just singularly focused on creating incredible plant based meals.
We have parameters by which they need to stay from both like cost of the meals
and the cost of ingredients,
uh,
the time it's gonna take to make a dish.
Um,
some of the,
you know,
we try not to have more than one of the three meals every week require a food
processor just to find the balance,
not make them too complex,
which we tend to be a little bit more chefy than maybe I would like.
But,
uh,
it is that experience,
but the flavors,
you know,
it's,
I really have to just,
you know,
um,
applaud the work that our chef sue to create incredible things.
They,
um,
the mushroom dish you mentioned though,
comes from a couple of friends of mine who run a company called wicked healthy.
Uh,
Derek and Chad Sarno,
who are really incredible vegan chefs and a,
yeah,
they take these king oyster mushrooms and they taste and feel like scallops are
incredible.
Um,
and so you'd never know that,
you know,
for someone who wants to make those transition from eating a sort of a more
traditional diet to one that's more plant based,
how,
um,
how far things have come.
And with innovation using oyster mushrooms that you slice and you saute a bit,
uh,
it looks,
it tastes,
it feels like,
uh,
like a scalp.
So,
um,
it's cool,
but there's,
um,
I think there's a,
uh,
what we try to do is make our meals tastes so good that you don't miss the meat.
You don't miss those flavors.
Um,
and again,
we're trying to get someone to do that three nights a week.
We're not saying be Vegan.
Uh,
as I said,
I'm not Vegan.
I don't preach veganism through our company.
And I think that's,
you know,
that's gotta be someone's personal choice for the majority of people that aren't
choosing that.
I think if you start eating them this three nights a week,
you might say,
wow,
that's actually really good and you almost become more inclined to watch the
documentary is to start seeing things and not as much in terms of the shocking,
horrible animal treatment that exists that I think a lot of us stick our head in
the sand and don't want to pay attention to that animal suffering.
And we don't ever talk about that within our company.
I think that's a hard thing to trade upon,
but I think for those people that start to get curious about it and learn more,
uh,
you begin that starts to seep in and you know,
once the genie's out of the bottle,
it's hard to put it back in.
Um,
and so if we can just get people to make some gentle shifts over time,
uh,
without saying,
hey,
everybody's got to go be Vegan,
that I think that's unsustainable.
But if we can all make some subtle changes in our diet,
the impact we can make collectively is really quite pronounced.
Hi,
thank you so much.
My name is Alex.
I work on Google Express.
And we try to connect people to their local stores like target and Costco.
And I'm in doing,
so we noticed that when competing with Amazon,
these local stores a struggle on the operation side and the shipping and how
those purple carrot deal with that.
I take it a little bit deeper from the operations of just shipping to our
customers or
shipping to the customers and getting things within the two days or fast
delivery that other meal kit companies have also struggled with.
Sure.
Okay.
Thank you for the question.
So,
um,
when I first launched the company,
we were started in my garage for the first month and then uh,
we moved into a slightly more proper facility but it was not so proper.
And uh,
we had no heat through that winter weight.
We launched in October,
so November we were in this facility by December,
it was starting to snow in Boston and it was just bloody cold for the next 90
days and a lot of snow that winter.
And we were in this warehouse with no heat and you know,
our product was,
we weren't so worried about it losing freshness,
but we're limiting it to one and two day ground shipping with a FedEx truck.
Um,
we use insulation and Gel packs and um,
the produce would hold up.
We were learning that,
you know,
Bazell might wilt,
uh,
almost gets too cold and it would turn black and it would perish as we moved
into the summer with no air conditioning either.
Uh,
and we're in this warehouse that was just like 90 degrees.
It was miserable.
Those products would also start to wilt in the heat.
So that wasn't,
we sort of quickly got ourselves out of that as we realized that was not working
so well.
Uh,
we're in the box and still be a lot of,
you know,
for Gel packs and thick insulation.
Um,
and again,
limiting it to one or two day ground shipping was sort of key for us that in our
test that we never want to just go longer than that in the box.
By November of 2015 about one year after I launched,
we opened up a west coast distribution center and we moved out of our facilities
into also a more proper place.
It was a cold room that we were packing our product and cold.
Um,
and so from both distribution centers in Boston and La,
they were always add packed in a cold rooms and then packed into boxes with
installation gel packs,
limiting it to one and two day ground shipping.
Uh,
we then moved to our Boston facility in New York for broader reach and a bit
more efficiency.
Uh,
we've just opened up a third distribution center in Ohio and so now we have a
hundred percent coverage in the content.
So you asked with one or two day ground shipping,
uh,
there are some customers that we need to do a two day air,
which we don't want it to be doing it and we're moving to move that third
facility to have the capacity to get everyone meals within one or two days from
when they ship a with a truck rather than using an airplane.
Um,
the downside to that is the requirement on installation.
we have had some learnings and experiences where we had a thickness to our boxes
and just this summer we went through a problem where we had some insulation that
was,
we needed to add more gel packs to keep it cold because the insulation was
failing.
So that was sort of a whole separate story with our supplier that caused me some
gray hair on my head to add to what's there already.
And putting more gel packs in.
Men started to compromise the integrity of the box.
And so you'd,
people would get boxes that were beat up in the box would,
would compress under the weight of the of Gel packs.
And the gel packs were melting faster cause there wasn't the installation.
So it becomes sort of a snowball effect.
And we were able to quickly shift to a thicker box and that issue is gone away
and we changed the liners.
But you know,
and so it's a really,
the amount of complexity that I think happens in the meal kit space is really
pronounced and to get incredibly fresh and incredibly fragile produce.
A lot of times,
especially in a plant based meal kit where we're not relying on,
you know,
chicken or beef or other animal protein as the source,
we're really having to bulk up on,
on great vegetables and grains that some of that stuff is really fragile and
also hard to source.
So it can be complex if you are sourcing,
you know,
a watermelon radish,
well we had issues where the watermelon radish was too big and it was supposed
to meet Spec but the suppliers couldn't get us the smaller water round radishes.
Now you have a big watermelon radish,
it's gonna throw the flavors,
then you have to go and cut the watermelon radish in half.
And that,
you know,
that worked because there was stability to that product.
And onion wouldn't hold up nearly as well,
if at all.
Um,
so there's,
there's decisions that we have to make every single week sort of throughout the
week based on what the supply chain enables us to access.
And you know,
I think what blue aprons done to control a lot of the supply chain is brilliant
because they should have sort of the best pick of the produce and suppliers are
growing things just for them.
So that should enable them to avoid some of those challenges that we face as a
smaller company.
Um,
but getting it to someone in a really fresh manner is certainly the most
important piece.
And when our suppliers like a FedEx or on track deliver,
sometimes they miss and you know,
but we have to own that so we can't go back to the customer say,
sorry on track,
messed up this week.
We have to then take that and need to refund them or give them credit.
So it's,
uh,
yeah,
it's challenging,
but I love it.
Thank you.
Um,
so I have some of it of a related question on packaging's.
Sure.
One of the common criticisms of meal kits is that it involves a lot of packaging
and that's one of the things that's given me pause about trying it out.
Yup.
Um,
so I'm just curious like how do you think about environmental sustainability in
your packaging?
And I work in finance.
I'm always curious about the numbers.
Like do you know how much the impact of packaging and transport,
how does that offset the environmental benefits accrued from actually eating a
plant based diet?
Sure.
Yeah.
We're actually starting to study the,
that exact issue.
Um,
what I can tell you is we're very aware of the of the challenge with
installation.
Uh,
I'd say by and large is the single largest complaint against meal kits is how
much packaging and insulation goes in to get the customer.
They are relatively small amount of food as compared to the size of the box that
is being shipped.
Um,
we have moved over time from sort of more standard installation to recyclable
installation.
Uh,
we were were through the spring that we were using the first a hundred percent
curbside recyclable installation.
Um,
and we're now into,
we,
we then now use a,
um,
a recycled installation that's made from water bottles that's been recycled down
from that,
that is then further recyclable.
Um,
all of our boxes are recycled,
bald,
the baggies,
the bottles,
everything can be recycled.
So we do our best to minimize that impact.
And I think broadly speaking,
the industry is aware of that and more and more companies are helping consumers
get comfortable with that idea that you can at least recycle the product,
that,
that is being shipped to you from the,
the what's required to get you those fresh items.
Um,
but it's,
you know,
as a plant based company,
which has a big connection to environmental sustainability,
it's incumbent upon us,
I believe as a company to have the words match our actions or the actions match
our words.
Uh,
so that we're continuing to innovate.
Um,
I'm pleased with what we've accomplished in a relatively short period of time.
I think the gel packs is a piece that we're looking at taking frozen water
bottles and using that.
So you put frozen water bottles into the packing and let that cool.
The produce that is in there,
then you can drink your water bottles,
recycled water bottle,
and you've got really zero impact as compared to the gel packs that,
I mean,
people have a little discomfort about having either squeeze those out or throw
them away.
It feels like a lot,
especially if you order on a regular basis,
they build up.
I feel like my God,
what am I doing with all these?
Um,
so it's,
it's no doubt a challenge.
I think,
you know,
if people factor in the gas that they're using to drive to the grocery store.
And also you think about the amount of impact that grocers have with respect to
receiving,
you know,
truckloads of groceries that come in.
There's a massive amount of,
you know,
sort of violation,
if you will,
that happens at the grocery level that I think people forget about and assign
all of that to the meal kit.
And so it's,
you know,
I think it's the reality that we have about,
uh,
the impact we make.
But I think that there's also a relative falsehood that it's the carbon emission
that happens from transportation that is so big,
when in fact it's the animal agriculture that's even bigger than that.
So hopefully we can move people in that direction.
Yeah.
Um,
so do you have any advice for young entrepreneurs and how did your time at Nyu
stern an sales impact career?
Yeah,
thanks for the question.
Um,
so if you're a young entrepreneur,
I would,
uh,
I'd build on what I said already about,
um,
following Seth Goden and reading his teachings.
I would drink up every single thing that you can on that.
Uh,
and Guy Kawasaki is a great resource as well.
Gary Vee is a pretty,
um,
he's,
he's out there with what he says.
He's got a particular style,
but he's all about entrepreneurship as well.
Um,
I think more than anything though,
it's having the courage and confidence to take the leap and not wait for the
perfect moment because there's never a better time than right now to start your
company.
Uh,
what people have,
the resources that are available today than was available last year or five
years ago or 15 or 20 years ago,
certainly is incredible.
And you don't need permission to start.
You just have to have the guts to do it.
Um,
and you know,
access to capital is so much easier today than it's ever been before.
You can publish on your own.
You don't need permission to do that.
Um,
and the economy is supportive of startups.
And so I think the idea of being able to create,
create a business and you know,
using tools like slack that enables you to be,
you know,
uh,
disconnected from your people from a proximity perspective,
but stay connected,
uh,
the tools that are available to build websites,
you know,
rapid fashion,
uh,
the,
the opportunities are right in front of you and it's,
it feels great to try to make a difference and to test yourself every day with
that and give yourself a challenge that is so different than working in
corporate America with all due respect to corporate America where I spend a fair
bit of my career.
Um,
but it's great and once you get the bug,
you'll never go back.
Um,
and I don't think I could ever work again in corporate America and never plants
who,
um,
and I think for those young entrepreneurs that are thinking about that,
uh,
to do it and to just play the long game and know when you've got to quit that,
if it's not working so that you have the chance to try the next thing and the
next thing and the next thing.
And hopefully you make some money along the way and you can then roll that into
your next,
uh,
next approach.
You know,
Nyu was,
um,
it was five years of a lot of pain.
It costs me a lot of money.
It costs me a lot of my time.
The fact that I have an Mba,
I don't think it really mattered.
I have to say,
I wish I could think differently about it.
I think those who go fulltime have a much different experience.
I went part time and went from seven to 10:00 PM for classes most nights for
five years.
And that was a really draining and I don't think I had the best teachers at
those hours.
Uh,
so I think someone thinks about an MBA should do it full time and go all in.
And instead of doing like me,
which was squeezing it in while I worked,
um,
and sales is just a great tool to be able to know how to sell them.
Whether you're selling a product or you're selling an idea,
whether you're trying to convince your spouse,
you know,
where to go on vacation or you know,
tell your kids what food to eat.
It's all sales at the end of the day.
And so,
uh,
being able to sell ice to Eskimos or anywhere in between,
is a really important tool and a skill that I encouraged for anybody.
Then on a related note,
um,
aside from meal kit delivery services,
what other opportunities for entrepreneurship do you see in the plant based
space?
So,
um,
you know,
there's plant based space is growing by leaps and bounds and it's projected to
grow from about a $13 billion industry to $25 billion industry in the next five
years.
Uh,
so there's a lot of growth there.
I think,
you know,
product development is a huge area of,
of innovation,
um,
to think about educating people with,
you know,
different types of products that are plant based.
Um,
you know,
the,
I think the area of education is,
is,
um,
is great opportunity,
whether it's like teaching people how to cook,
plant based or um,
uh,
even providing services to help people become more plant based and sort of be,
someone's sort of chaperoned,
threw us through a process.
Um,
there's probably interesting innovation opportunities there.
Uh,
but I would also not incur,
you know,
it doesn't,
you don't have to be an entrepreneur just in the plant based space.
I mean,
the plant based space I think is really cool and I love what I'm doing and the
difference that I make by being in a plant based space versus selling or trying
to promote other things.
Um,
but I would say if someone's interested in playing bass is a great thing is go
do expo east or expo west.
Expo West is in Anaheim.
Expo East is in Baltimore.
Those conferences happen twice a year.
It's,
it will open your eyes up to the incredible,
uh,
growth of the category and the number of products that are,
servicing those people who care about health and wellness,
uh,
through the foods and choices that they make.
So that'd be worth going to.
Thank you.
One other question.
Oh,
no.
Okay.
All right.
Thanks so much.